[Musique]
bonjour à tous pour le deuxième
trimestre consécutif le nombre
d'inscrits à pôle emploi a augmenté une
augmentation plus nette encore en
bourgogne franche comté alors doit-on
encore rêver à l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage le gouvernement at il pris
les bonnes décisions on en parle et on
en débat ce dimanche matin en direct
restez avec nous pour dimanche en
politique a tout de suite
dégustez votre programme avec les
produits bio bonne terre
aujourd'hui et ici on voyageait dans le
temps au moyen-âge par exemple
l'occasion de rencontrer quelques
passionnés qui vous initieront aux us et
coutumes d'antan à guédelon vous
découvrirez le travail inouï des
bâtisseurs le savoir faire des artisans
mais si vous préférez faire la fête eh
bien vous pourrez toujours aller danser
à saint bérain ne bougeait pas le
moyen-âge c'est là aujourd'hui à 12h 55
sur france 3 bourgogne franche comté
[Musique]
les prix du gaz ne cesse d'augmenter +
28 % en six mois dit stop
changer pour eni ait bénéficié de -15%
sur le prix de votre gaz
appelez vite le 32 94 et ni élu meilleur
fournisseur énergétique de l'année
pour vous bien manger c'est essentiel
alors faites confiance à bleu blanc
coeur qui organise une agriculture dédié
à la santé des animaux de la terre et
des hommes
[Musique]
faites confiance aux assurés aviva qui
recommande aviva à 95% à la suite du
traitement de leur sinistre auto
aviva
découvrez maintenant l'egypte a fait un
vrai café au lait équilibrée et riche en
goût et facile à digérer matin léger
café pour retrouver tous les plaisirs du
lait
[Musique]
lundi il ya les allemands qui impose un
régime tout à fait d'un gain qui divise
le pays n'y a aucun commerce entre les
deux zones qu'on autorise la fin comme
véritable arme de guerre pour nourrir 80
millions de soldats pendant la grande
guerre
il a fallu développer l'industrie
alimentaire certains vont découvrir pour
la première fois des boîtes de conserve
en 1914 très cher il s'est même pas
ouvrir la boîte et comment la faire
cuire au menu des poilus lundi après le
soir 3 sur france 3 bourgogne franche
comté suivi du légiste des poilus une
enquête extraordinaire pour identifier
le corps du soldat
claude fournier
[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne pour le deuxième trimestre
consécutif le nombre d'inscrits à pôle
emploi en france métropolitaine a
augmenté au troisième trimestre + 0 4 %
en bourgogne franche comté le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi augmente encore plus
nettement +1 2% c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle évidemment pour le gouvernement
qui promet depuis longtemps des
lendemains meilleurs sur le front de
l'emploi grâce notamment aux réformes
engagées
alors pourquoi le chômage ne fléchit
qu'il par les réformes engagées sont
elles réellement efficace l'assurance
chômage
doit-elle être complètement réformé ou
encore le plein emploi en france est il
une utopie on en débat ce matin en
direct avec nos invités fadila khattabi
bonjour vous êtes député la république
en marche de côte-d'or benoît vidaud
bonjour président de la ceppm bourgogne
franche comté l'une des principales
organisations patronales sophie beaudry
bonjour je vous représentez ici la
france insoumise moïse maillot bonjour
je vous êtes le directeur régional de
l'insee vous nous éclairer sur la
situation concrète notamment dans notre
région
merci à tous les cas d'avoir accepté
cette invitation vous qui nous regarde
et vous pouvez bien sûr commenter cette
émission avec le hashtag dit mme paul
bourgogne avant de vous donner la parole
mesdames messieurs je vous propose
quelques données en chiffre qui devrait
éclairer notre débat c'est avec michel
dernier c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
le gouvernement
au troisième trimestre 0,4 pour cent de
chômeurs en plus soit seize mille 400
demandeurs d'emploi supplémentaires
après une baisse au début du quinquennat
de trois millions sept cent cinquante
mille à trois millions 690 me pour les
chômeurs de catégorie à ceux qui ne
travaillent pas du tout c'est le
deuxième trimestre consécutif de hausse
depuis le début de l'année
c'est un paradoxe si les créations
d'emplois ont enregistré un record cet
été les chômeurs ont du mal en
bénéficier et à retrouver du travail
plus de deux millions de contrats de
travail ont été signés entre juillet et
septembre
mais le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
longue durée ceux qui sont inscrits
depuis plus d'un an n'a cessé de
progresser
6 4% de plus depuis septembre 2017
ils sont 2 millions 8 aujourd'hui malgré
cette hausse le gouvernement affiche son
optimisme et confirme l'objectif d'un
taux de chômage ramené à 7% à la fin du
quinquennat
alors fadila khattabi est ce que cette
inversion de la courbe du chômage qu'on
attend finalement toujours ses
difficultés en matière d'emploi c'est le
premier échec de votre majorité de votre
gouvernement est finalement d'emmanuel
macron je ne parlerai pas pour ma part
d'échec nous ne sommes élu que depuis un
an et demi sur un an et demi il y a eu
un travail considérable de fait
notamment le vote de trois lois la loi
travail lesdites les ordonnances pour
ramener de la confiance libérer les
énergies renforcer le dialogue ça fait
déjà un an que c'est en place et tout un
tas quand même des résultats dans la
mesure où le nombre de contrats en cdi a
augmenté sur l'année 10 % donc je parle
sous couvert bien sûr de monsieur mais
de 10% ce qui est tout à fait nouveau
tout à fait nouveau il y a eu ensuite la
loi sur la formation professionnelle
pour la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel qui prévoit un plan massif
de formation un investissement dans les
ressources humaines de 15 milliards pour
former un million de demandeurs d'emploi
et un million de jeunes dont créé pour
la bourgogne franche comté
on a reçu la ministre du travail au mois
d'avril qui a contractualisé avec l'état
donc à hauteur de 26 millions d'euros
pour l'année 2018 il y en aura autant
l'année prochaine et enfin en septembre
nous avons voté une loi en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale la loi
pacte plan d'action pour la croissance
et la transformation des entreprises
dont l'objectif est de faire grandir nos
entreprises notamment le nombre de
d'entreprises de taille intermédiaire et
surtout de partir à la conquête aussi de
marché à l'export de développer aussi
faire en sorte que les entreprises
puissent effectivement partir à la
conquête donc de nouveaux marchés benoît
xvi l'eau est ce que les entrepreneurs
trouvent leur compte dans les réformes
que vient d'énoncer fadila khattabi en
sachant que visiblement il ya encore un
gros soucis d'emploi en france en partie
on a on soutient certaines mesures de
cette loi d'autres parce qu'on est
exprimé sur lequel on est un peu plus
circonspect
on fait attention à ce qu'ils pourraient
poindre également les effets n'ont
mesuré de de cette loi pour revenir à
l'emploi parce que c'est le sujet
effectivement il est tout n'est pas noir
il ya une deux trimestres de hausse
après une baisse quand même importante
qui a lieu en début de quinquennat
maintenant on a du mal à attribuer aux
effets des premières réformes d'emmanuel
macron mais peut-être plus à l'est au
cicr françois hollande non je fais pas
je fais pas de 2,2 d'analyseurs lier les
deux les deux sont liés il ya des effets
le cdi l'art assurance dans le s'est dit
à nouveau contracté un cdi quand tu
entrepreneur sans avoir de risque
potentiel très important c'était une
bonne chose le cic eux étaient également
une bonne chose mais c'est surtout la
croissance de nos entreprises qui
génèrent de l'emploi et on a
l'impression que ça ne suffit pas on a
beau flexibiliser le marché de l'emploi
la loi travail la précédente loi travail
la fameuse loi les conneries et ça ne
suffit toujours pas est ce qu il vous en
faut plus et j'ai envie dire est ce qu
il vous en faut toujours plus une
croissance pérenne inscrits dans le
temps qui durerait
naturellement vous verriez la courbe du
chômage qui s'inverse puisque c'est la
croissance qui va générer de l'emploi
c'est le facteur numéro un
oui donc toutes ces réformes ne vous
êtes pas signé d'un grand sens que c'est
vous les entreprises alors la croissance
généré de la croissance c'est être
aujourd'hui compétitifs à l'échelle
nationale internationale ou européenne
et si les lois qui viennent poindre sur
nos entreprises demain mais nous
permettre d'être compétitifs de se
développer d'agrandir la taille de nos
entreprises d'aller chercher des marchés
ailleurs de s'orienter vers des nouveaux
métiers de faire la transformation
digitale des tpe/pme indispensables à
leur développement demain et bien là il
y aura de l'emploi et tout ça ce sont
des mesures que nous on porte sur
lesquels on souhaiterait demain avoir un
accélérateur très fort quand je vous
écoute je me dis c'est pas près
d'arriver c'est à dire que tout ce que
vous énoncez ça va prendre du temps
ça prend toujours du temps maintenant la
mesure on aimerait bien ou d'un coup de
baguette magique demain tout ce qu'on
demande soit
[Rires]
non non non on le construit on le
construit on construit de manière de
manière acharnée c'est à dire qu'on l'a
jamais le bifteck qui nous paraît être
la bonne solution
maintenant il ya des avancées une chose
qui tarde un peu plus et puis vous avez
travaillé sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage on y reviendra bien évidemment
mais laisser les partenaires sociaux qui
sont à la manoeuvre sur cette question
là et ça influe rap ou pas on verra sur
sur cette courbe du chômage sophie
beaudry vous ça apporte finalement de
l'eau à votre moulin ce premier échec ce
que j'appelle le premier échec même si
fadila khattabi n'est pas d'accord de
d'emmanuel macro ont finalement françois
hollande était un peu parti pour la même
raison
nous ce qu'on constate c'est que le
chômage de masse que vivent les français
actuellement c'est la conséquence
effectivement des des politiques qui ont
été menées sous les mandats de sarkozy
épi dolan dans ce n'est que la
continuité c'est le résultat de la
financiarisation de l'économie des
politiques libérales qui pour nous sont
un véritable échec et même effectivement
les mesurettes proposées actuellement
selon les estimations ne créera pas plus
de 50000 emplois et l'investissement qui
est prévu dans la formation ce serait
des effets qui se verraient que dans
deux à trois ans donc pour nous le
gouvernement fait évidemment fausse
route vers vous vous taxer plus les
patrons comme benoît milot et puis vous
créez des emplois publics qu'est-ce que
vous faites si vous arrivez aux
responsabilités alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait déjà on s'interroge par exemple sur
la mise en place du cic on a 24
milliards d'euros qui sont dépensés
comme ça de façon indistincte qui
retombe sur toutes les entreprises
il s'avère qu'effectivement il ya des
secteurs qui sont aux tensions qui
mériterait une partie de ces deux c'est
de cet argent
mais peut-être pas toutes les sociétés
et toutes les entreprises les
multinationales en profite beaucoup at
elle véritablement besoin d' avantages
fiscaux de ce type là à savoir c'est la
première dépense fiscale de l'état
voilà c'est des questions qui peuvent se
poser donc cette énorme argent qui
pourrait créer des emplois d'utilité
sociale comme les a's ash les avs par
exemple tous les emplois autour des
secteurs de la petite enfance des jeux
souvent deux emplois aidés bien sûr oui
oui et 2 en droit public
oui effectivement le l'état pourrait
effectivement joué un rôle important
j'ai vu au vaudeville au hacker c'est
quand vous avez dit les grandes sociétés
n'ont pas besoin parce que oui les
patrons de pme disent ça aussi il
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu fléché ces
aides en fonction des logements le
secteur
en crise en tension comme disait sur
l'utilisation du cic eux n'a pas été
alors elle a été à la sauver des
entreprises
elle a sauvé des entreprises ville
anciennement ça c'est clair on peut pas
on peut pas dire le contraire dans une
période de crise dure maintenant on est
capable de faire des différences sur la
taxation des entreprises qu'elles soient
multinationales aujourd'hui et qu'elle
soit tpe pme pour qu'on l'a pas fait
pour le séisme on est capable de faire
des différences d'imposition n'est
capable de pas taxer les géants du net
dans le commerce
aujourd'hui qui est numérique et de
taxer les petits commerçants avec une
tasse comme des taxes sur les enseignes
des trucs qui augmente on marche sur la
tête ont fait cette différence puis d'un
autre côté on la prépare pour les aides
on la fait pas donc oui je suis un peu
d'accord avec ce que dit à ma voisine
sur l'utilisation des fonds du cicg
c'est la première dépense fiscale de
l'état 24 milliards d'euros c'est énorme
on nous répète tout le temps qu'il a pas
d'argent s'il ya de l'argent ou et il me
c'est la question fadila khattabi
torcheux la parole à moïse maillot pour
comprendre un peu ce qui se passe je
souscris à ce qui vient d'être dit
effectivement mais le cic eux avaient
quand même donné certains fruits
positifs et nous ont la facilité
effectivement avec une baisse des
charges clair et pas avec en fonction du
chiffre d'affaires est de -1 et c'est
donc les entreprises demandé plus de
simplification
après je vous le dis franchement nous
ferons de toute façon l'évaluation des
mesures que nous votons actuellement on
fera une évaluation des ordonnances on
fera une évaluation de la loi sur la
formation professionnelle tout comme
nous ferons une évaluation sur la loi
pacte parce que c'est important le rôle
aussi du député aujourd'hui pas de
dépenser de l'argent inconsidérément
c'est aussi d'évaluer d'évaluer et de
voir effectivement on arrête quoi voilà
ou alors on peut amender des évaluations
ont été faites quand même je rappelle d
étude du cnrs et de francs stratégie qui
ont évalué que pour 24 milliards d'euros
il ya eu cent mille emplois qui ont été
créés ce qui revient à 200000 euros par
emploi dont c'est simplement aider comme
emploi ça on s'est sacrément et des
nounous effectivement socialement on
estime que c'est pas bien pas très bien
investi clamant mouiller le maillot
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à
cette fameuse inversion de la courbe du
chômage même si je sais que vous allez
me dire que sur un an le chômage a
baissé et c'est vrai mais on voit bien
que ça remonte de temps en temps qu'il
ya d'autres facteurs qui entrent en
considération et peut-être qui
évidemment la croissance n'y est pas
pour rien connaissances atone
juste d'abord j'aimerais bien revenir
sur la définition du chômage au sens du
bureau international du travail
être chômeur cela veut dire ne pas avoir
travaillé ne serait-ce une pendant la
semaine de référence
ça veut dire être disponible dans les 15
jours pour prendre un emploi et enfin
faire acte de recherche active d'emploi
l'inscription à pôle emploi n'est pas
n'étant pas en tant que tel une
recherche active d'emploi
les chiffres que j'ai données sont ceux
de pôle emploi et il concerne les
chômeurs de catégorie a
oui ça se ressemble conceptuellement
c'est à peu près complètement ça se
ressemble
mais il ya une différence tout même
parce que tous les chômeurs ne sont pas
inscrits à pôle emploi et il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui sont inscrites à pôle
emploi mais qu'ils ne satisfont pas aux
conditions que je viens d'énoncer ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ya plus de chômeurs
que viendront alors le le taux de
chômage au sens du bureau international
du travail lui s'élève à 8 7% en france
et à 7 7% en banque en franche comté au
deuxième trimestre est ce qu'on calcule
également c'est ce qu'on appelle le halo
du chômage parce que ce qui est
important c'est de mesurer le les
frontières grise qui existe entre emploi
et chômage et entre chômage et une
activité qu'est ce que vous appelez les
frontières grise
par exemple une pour être chômeur il
faut faire un acte de recherche
il ya des mères au foyer alors j'emploie
le terme de mère au foyer parce que
c'est quand même la majorité des
personnes qui restent au foyer
aujourd'hui qui qui souhaitent
travailler mais qui ne font pas d'acte
de recherche
donc elles ne sont pas comptés dans le
taux de chômage mais elles sont comptés
comme inactive inactivé donc ce qu'on
appelle le halo du chômage c'est toutes
ces frontières enfin un petit peu grise
les chiffres qu'on a qu'on a vu tomber
la semaine dernière les chefs de pôle
emploi qui sont désormais trimestriels
montrent que en bourgogne franche comté
il y à une plus forte hausse mais c'est
assez nette 1 + 1 2 % par rapport au
niveau national où c'est plus 0,4
est ce que vous vous l'expliquer cette
différence il ya au niveau de la
bourgogne franche comté il y a quelques
problèmes qui auxquelles doit faire face
à un problème entre guillemets le
premier c'est que c'est la bourgogne
franche comté a un poids de la un poids
de l'emploi industriel beaucoup plus
élevé puisque c'est le premier
la première région industrielle avec un
taux d'emploi avec un emploi qui
représente à peu près 18 % de l'emploi
dans la région
alors c'est justement ce qui est six
pour cent de plus que le niveau national
c'est ça et comme l'industrie première
couche était à quelques difficultés on
le voit très nettement quand on découpe
par département on voit que par exemple
c'est la saône et loire aujourd'hui qui
connaît la plus forte hausse est un
département fortement industrialisée et
on voit par exemple quand du côté de la
franche comté le territoire de belfort
où la haute saône qui sont aussi très
industrialisés sont aussi en haut du
peloton de cette hausse peut s'expliquer
en partie par le fait que l'emploi qui a
été créée en 2017 a été fortement un
emploi intérimaire qui la progression
d'un pôle intérimaire a porté la
progression de l'emploi en bourgogne
franche comté et cette progression a
nettement diminué sur l'année 2018 alors
qu'est ce qui explique en partie cette
cette position on a vu aussi que le
nombre au niveau national nombre de
chômeurs de longue durée continue à
augmenter là aussi comment ça s'explique
en fait il ya il y à un sondage qui
expliquait que pour les employeurs 9 -
de chômage correspondait à peu près à
quatre ans de pertes de vie
professionnelle il ya un bourgogne
franche comté environ la moitié des
inscrits à pôle emploi sont des chômeurs
de longue durée de plus d'un an et sa
femme aurait cent mille personnes et là
dedans il y en a à peu près 30 milles
qui sont au chômage depuis plus de trois
ans donc c'est aussi la difficulté de
retrouver de retrouver un travail
s'éloigne considérablement du marché de
l'emploi c'est de plus en plus difficile
oui c'est de plus en plus difficile et
c'est également liée au fait que la
croissance a été moindre que prévu en
particulier au cours du premier semestre
liée à une hausse des prix des matières
premières et en particulier du pétrole
qui l'un prix du pétrole a rebondi lié à
une baisse du pouvoir d'achat qui a
entraîné une baisse de la consommation
au premier semestre qui doit repartir
d'après les prévisions que l'insee
réalise actuellement
et puis par des perturbations
internationales sur sur le commerce et
sur le protectionnisme qui font que l'a7
cette croissance a été moindre que ce
qui était prévu
l'année dernière fadila khattabi
emmanuel la con quand il a été élu ça
devait être le champion de la croissance
et patatras écoutez la croissance malgré
tout on n'est pas complètement
complètement atone je veux dire elle est
là les bons chiffres
gillot espère le chiffre effectivement
est perfectible mais je voudrais
répondre par rapport au chômage de masse
au chômage de longue durée ce qui est
aussi important c'est d'investir
massivement dans certaines formations
notamment dans certains sur certaines
filières des métiers en tension
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est que
on a plutôt négligé la voie
professionnelle
on n'a pas suffisamment travaillé sur
l'apprentissage
on n'a pas suffisamment non plus
anticiper les mutations économiques et
technologiques et c'est donc ce qui est
important aussi c'est de travailler à la
fois sur les formations mais travailler
aussi
sur l'orientation est revalorisé
certaines filières notamment par exemple
l'industrie qui recherchent moi j'avais
discuté cet automne avec le drh de
peugeot qui recherchait certaines
compétences qu'ils ne trouvaient pas
donc là aussi il ya un gros un grand
paradoxe à savoir ya des offres d'emploi
et en même temps il ya des demandeurs
d'emploi qui cherche mais qui ne
trouvent encore réduit sa déception
d'abord sophie bris puis ensuite benoît
vidaud sur cette adéquation avec les
besoins des entreprises
moi je me pose la question comment
accompagner les chômeurs quand on a plus
on a des portefeuilles de plusieurs
centaines de personnes quand on est
conseiller à pôle emploi
il peut pas y avoir d'accompagnement
individuel les moyens ne sont pas mis
pour un véritable accompagnement pour le
retour à l'emploi
donc les conseillers ne sont pas
forcément ni compétents ni formés et
n'ont pas les moyens de travailler de
cette façon là ne parlons même pas de ce
qui s'est passé à un haut niveau d
études universitaires et de la baisse
effectivement des moyens de parcours
super enfin bon clairement pour nous on
va pas dans le bon sens un madame
beaudry il va y avoir une réponse vous
avez raison il faut renforcer ce qu'on
appelle le concert évolution
professionnelle le général le
généraliser sur l'ensemble du territoire
il va y avoir un grand marché là dessus
pour pouvoir accompagner et les
personnes notamment les personnes les
plus vulnérables faille après vous
parlez de formation tout à l'heure le
gouvernement
le dernier gouvernement de françois
hollande et même le précédent avait mis
le paquet sur la formation ça avait fait
d'ailleurs machinalement sortir un
certain nombre de chômeurs de la
catégorie a est aujourd'hui ces
formations se terminer ces gens
reviennent chiffres du chômage ont
investi véritablement sur des formations
en fonction effectivement des besoins
aussi des entreprises et des besoins des
territoires mais pour ce faire il faut
accompagner et informer les personnes
or aujourd'hui je suis d'accord avec
vous pour l'emploi n'a pas les capacités
d'accompagner d'informer les demandeurs
d'emploi donc est ce que à un moment
donné il va y avait la police c'était la
privatisation de vaud l'emploi ou
confiance et je disais tout à l'heure il
va y avoir un grand marché et les gens
pourront les structures pourront se
positionner effectivement pour faire de
l'accompagnement et du constat sûr que
ça plaise à la france a soumis ce n'est
pas trop il faut bientôt peut-être plus
quand on voit le marché de la haute
placement on se dit qu'il a de beaux
jours devant lui en apporter aujourd'hui
en tout cas les prescripteurs
traditionnel ce qu'on appelle les big
five les cinq à pouvoir pôle emploi
missions locales etc n'ont pas
suffisamment de moyens pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins et quand on est en
face d'un
chômage de masse je crois qu'il est
important d'accompagner notamment les
plus vulnérables parce que c'est bien
beau effectivement quand on a un panel
de formations
encore faut-il pouvoir construire son
projet alors questionner les le
construire sur la durée et pouvoir aussi
connaître les besoins sur un territoire
or beaucoup de sursaut l'énergie les
concessionnaires et de pôle emploi est
plutôt orienté vers le comment dire le
contrôle des chômeurs et leur style même
s'ils n'ont pas dû à vous voulez dire
que vous regrettez la fusion de deux des
assedic avec l'anpe en quelque sorte
besoins vitaux
fadila khattabi par led adéquation entre
les besoins des entreprises le fameux
marché de l'emploi et la formation est
ce que pour vous c'est un problème
et qu'est ce que vous préconisez pour
essayer de trouver des solutions
oui c'est un problème parce que quand on
parle de chômage du chômage qui augmente
et qu'on voit quand même temps en france
et deux cent cinquante mille offres
d'emploi non pourvues par an et qu'à
l'échelle locale on n'a rien qu'autour
de mon conseil d'administration à la
cpmt côte-d'or je n'aime pas la
bourgogne franche comté où le problème
numéro un des chefs d'entreprise c'est
le recrutement on se dit qu'il ya
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas
forcément bien entre l'adéquation des
gens qui recherchent dans l'emploi et
les emplois proposés vous qu'est ce que
vous pouvez faire
non ce qu'on peut faire c'est évidemment
donner une cartographie qu'on nous
écoute sur les emplois qui sont et les
métiers en tension
on les communique on le faisait par
l'intermédiaire d'une dune d'une
information qu'on faisait avec l'ordre
des experts comptables régulièrement ont
donné les métiers qui embauchent on va
telle règle voire plus a indiqué les
médias industriels les métiers du second
oeuvre du bâtiment qui ont des grosses
difficultés le travaux publics c'est un
petit peu plus un peu différent puisque
sont organisés pour effectivement
répondre à leur demande par des centres
de formation qui disons qu'ils ont sous
leur sur leur égide
ensuite les métiers de bouche on connaît
on connaît la difficulté des métiers de
bouche restauration hôtellerie mais plus
loin des métiers de bouche qui sont des
métiers ancestraux comme la boucherie la
poissonnerie les métiers plus
traditionnels
est-ce qu'on est comme le préconise
emmanuel macron est ce qu'on dit à un
horticulteur d'aller faire le serveur
dans un restaurant en traversant la rue
par exemple est ce que est ce que ces
gens là qui ont été formés pour un
métier doivent dire ok je change c'est
parce qu'on est en train de dire et nous
d'ailleurs le chef d'entreprise qui
reçoit un horticulteur qui arrive dans
un dans un restaurant ne peut être pas
forcément le prendre puisqu'il n'a pas
la formation ni ni la lys et c'est comme
une formation pour ces métiers on ne
vient pas d'horticulteurs restaurateurs
c'est à vous
ça arrive aussi seul ennui c'est
complètement idiot j'ai trouvé ça
complètement idiot cette remarque et
c'est vraiment un raccourci qui est
inutile et là on pense que c'est un peu
aussi ce que vous dites quand vous dites
il ya des emplois non pourvus c'est ça
que vous voulez dire emmanuel macron
mais il ya des emplois non pourvus il
faut deux à mener les gens plutôt vers
une formation sans les secteurs qui
embauchent
c'est là où je parle de cartographie
l'emploi c'est que demain on puisse
avoir une vraie visibilité de nos
métiers qui m'ont embauché demain et
former les jeunes jeunes ou les moins
jeunes parce que la formation des
seniors pour une reconversion
il ya des seniors qui sont le plus en
plus touchés par le par cette difficulté
d'emploi
eh bien oui les entreprises qui
embauchent pas dans tous les secteurs
les entreprises qui embauchent plus il
ya des métiers qui sont finis cela aussi
il faut en avoir conscience qu'on compte
s'opposer cartographier en disant à la
l'éducation nationale et aux haut lieux
de formation arrêté de former ces
métiers là mais à celle des métiers qui
se digitalise le plus vous savez on
remplace on remplace laval à la
plus-value humaine par une machine
finalement dans une intelligence
artificielle
arrêtons d'envoyer ces gens là dans des
filières qui n'embauchent plus et puis
revenons à des métiers qui sont
créateurs d'entreprise mais oui moi je
reviens sur sur le constat de dire
'voilà y ait des offres d'emploi mais
elles sont pas pourvus il s'avère qu'on
est dans un club à nice tu sais on est
dans un contexte de pénurie d'emplois 1
en 2017 on a des chiffres il ya 7,5 pour
cent des entreprises qui ne parvenait
pas à côté donc la difficulté de
recruter ça reste l'exception 1 c'est
pas la masse est pas la majorité des cas
un ongle le conte et la problématique se
pose autrement
sur les 300 mille offres d'emploi qui
sont non pourvus il ya des gars des ja
des contrats qui sont précaires il faut
plusieurs offres d'emploi
on a fait effectivement un parallèle il
ya une offre d'emploi pour 20 personnes
1 pour 20 pour un chômeur donc
clairement on n'est pas là pour moi le
diagnostic à la base il est pas bon déjà
le son on est dans un contexte de
pénurie d'emplois il faudrait une
volonté forte de l'état avec une vision
d'avenir sur les secteurs dans lesquels
il faudra investir pour relancer la
machine et créer de la croissance et ce
n'est pas le cas dans ça on vous dit il
faut de l'argent
oui mais non un plan on a sont investis
100 milliards d'euros dans l'économie de
la mer ne représente pas grand chose il
est quand même dommage de pas les
pourvoir et puis peut-être que je suis
d'accord ça représente pas en
pourcentage vous dites 300 milles par
rapport au nombre de chômeurs c'est l'un
pour 20 peut-être celle-ci déjà ses
trois cent mille font baisser la base ça
sera déjà une bonne chose
hockey pat et poussez pas suffisant
aussi un problème sur certaines filières
elles sont en mal d'image c'est vrai que
certains emplois dans la restauration
moi je suis désolé j'avais la matière
j'ai payé etc
ça donne pas forcément très envie et
puis les jeunes il faut les informer moi
personnellement j'ai quand même été
enseignant dans un cfa où on avait des
jeunes qui venaient par exemple dans la
restauration hôtellerie
ils venaient mais au bout de quatre mois
quatre mois il y avait une ruse effet
les courageux ils étaient découragés
donc là il ya aussi un travail
d'information à faire auprès de ceux de
ce public là et le redis il s'agissait
des chefs d'entreprises bien sûr leur ai
expliqué effectivement que ces jeunes
vont devoir travailler quand les jo les
autres effectivement leurs camarades
vont s'amuser vous avoir des loisirs on
travaille le week end on travaille les
jours fériés et c est peut-être aussi se
poser la question si de la rémunération
donc il ya tout ce travail à faire mais
moi je vois au niveau de la restauration
quand on dit souvent en mal d'image oui
mais il reste quand même ce métier par
exemple reste attractive pour de
nombreux jeunes
et puis aussi revaloriser la voie
professionnelle revaloriser
l'apprentissage
on a aussi sacrifié un grand nombre de
la fin des emplois et des shoots la
question aussi à moïse maillot ça a
plombé un peu vos chiffres non en
matière d'armes parce que nous
l'objectif c'est de créer enfin
d'investir dans la formation mais sur de
vrais emplois
le l'emploi idée aujourd'hui quand vous
dites quand vous dites aux avc etc ne
sont pas de raison non mais c'est pas ça
c'est à dire que il faut effectivement
des emplois aidés parce que il ya
certaines personnes qui ont besoin pour
répondre à la demande sociale répondre
aussi au monde associatif je dis pas le
contraire
donc on en a dans le budget de 2010 9 y
en a cent mille qui sont effectivement
au budget et 45000 effectivement ash
pour accompagner les les enfants en
situation d'handicap ou les personnes en
situation d'handicap donc 145000 donc
j'allais dire à la louche c'est
pratiquement le chiffre de l'an dernier
je dis pas qu'il ne faut pas il en faut
mais en même temps il ya le plan
d'investissement compétence 3 milliards
qui sont prévus dans le budget de 2010
parce qu'il nous reste deux minutes
d'émission moi j'ai envie de faire un
petit tour de table avec vous mouiller
le maillot s'il y avait une priorité
pour vous en matière d'emploi non pas
pour arriver au plein emploi mais enfin
en tous les cas
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'accès au
plein emploi est plutôt difficile par
contre toutes les mesures qui ont lieu
sur l'adéquation entre la formation
initiale et
et l'emploi et est prêt est extrêmement
importante pour les années qui viennent
en particulier parce que les ce qui va
arriver c'est qu'on va avoir sur le
marché du travail vont se présenter des
personnes nées dans les années 2000 avec
un baby boom sur en france et puis en
particulier en bourgogne franche comté
qui vont venir sur le marché du travail
mais sophie bordry même question nous on
est pour partager le temps de travail
c'est une réalité donc on vous revenir
aux 35 heures on veut la retraite à 60
ans on veut construire un système de
production écosocialiste au service de
la transition énergétique de l'économie
de la mer la restauration des services
publics ça serait plus 400 mille emplois
on a budgété chiffrer toutes ces choses
là on est prêt à les mettre en oeuvre
benoît vidaud autre priorité la priorité
pour l'emploi la croissance des
entreprises
l'allègement de la fiscalité des
entreprises la compétitivité de nos
entreprises la prise de marché de nos
entreprises qui va générer naturellement
de l'emploi donc pour nous il n'ya même
pas débat fadila khattabi que les 35
heures n'ont pas été abolie
contrairement à ce que vous dites
et puis c'est surtout un grand
investissement dans les ressources
humaines et faire grandir aussi nos
entreprises merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir accepté cette invitation ce
dimanche matin de débattre en direct
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis dans
un instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale avec elle a besoin
tu vis de la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique francis letellier
reçoit yannick jadot tête de liste
d'europe écologie les verts aux
élections européennes
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3
[Musique]